so as america continues to recover from  last year's shutdown people are trying  to head back to work caesars  entertainment wants to help with that  effort so more than 300 positions are  open at nine resorts on the strip the  hiring event is thursday from 10 to 2 at  the caesars employment center the  company is looking for everything from  guest room attendants truck drivers  laundry feeders and just that's just a  few of the positions that are open they  have several more  you must first apply online and again we  have that information on our website at  8newsnow.com if you're looking for a job  several other companies hiring we have  put together a list along with the links  to apply again listed on our website at  8newsnow.com just click on the job board  tab